hey what up this yg make sure you check
me out on the bullet kev podcast for one
boulet cab show special guest
my friend yg is here what's happening
dog a lot of jewelry better oh no just
light work you know what i'm saying
something like well first of all man
congrats um
uh you've just been killing it on all
fronts
i appreciate the you know just the
enterprises you're building uh 400
flowers the shoes the clothing line is
everywhere i feel like every time i go
to damn
zoomies you're like right in the front
window and [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
like
um
just man it's been a minute yeah bro
appreciate it dawg we did some zoom [ __ ]
i feel like over the pandemic um zoom
[ __ ] ain't rude of me that [ __ ] is whack
[ __ ] it's been a few years since we sat
down though man so it's good to see you
um let's just get let's just get this
[ __ ] out of the way
what's up bro
the rams niners thing
i've historically known you to be a 49er
fan me and you have had verbal arguments
about the 49ers because i'm a cardinal
fan you know these are on youtube
somewhere okay on my channel you
probably just look we got i just
realized we have like 12 interviews over
the years
so
now you're a rams fan i've been around
for them first okay so you've been
knowing me for
my like i met your whole life oh nine
2010 my my older my teenage adult like
you didn't know me since i was
like my youth correct
you feel me i grew up a rams fan my
father is a raps fan
i started doing my music [ __ ] moving
around
going to the bay
we knew some people that was from la
that played on the niners that was
inviting us to the games we started
going to the games young [ __ ]
who don't got a team in la crosse going
to the niner games like this is our
first
nfl game so we like [ __ ] we [ __ ] with
the niners cool for show niner game
so he was [ __ ] with the niners and we
start hanging with kaepernick and frank
gore's and michael crabtrees and all of
them uh sean golson is the one that
brought us up there like that boom we
get in
we in with them i'm the type of dude
you feel me i support
the teams or the people that i know like
so if i got a relationship with like
russell westbrook no you used to [ __ ]
with the thunder you used to yeah no no
for sure yeah them [ __ ] is from the
city so i'm supporting that mm-hmm so
that's how i got into the niners [ __ ]
but i was a rams fan first okay okay
feel me since a kid like real football
fan team not know oh cause i know this
person i know this person you feel me
it was rams and [ __ ] chicago bulls
michael jordan you see that's how it all
started
so um
and then i i i had to cut the niners off
when they
did the whole kaepernick [ __ ]
so i honestly don't
see how people is still uh supporting
the niners organization after the whole
kaepernick situation happened so i'm
proud and i'm glad to say [ __ ] the 49ers
i've been saying [ __ ] the 49ers when
that whole [ __ ] happened
they edited your song automatically
exactly so you want to go and you want
to bring up the past like you know
everything but you leaving [ __ ] out well
listen cause i don't understand how you
forgot about kaepernick maybe i'm angry
that your black people eliminated the
rams for black people he took a knee
how the [ __ ] am i supposed to [ __ ] with
the niners after they kicked him off the
team cut him out the envy i don't [ __ ]
with him bro
well that's fair yeah so so so now you
know i'm just a petty fan of the
cardinals who's mad that y'all [ __ ]
smoked us and got us the [ __ ] up out of
here for the year well i'm just a real
[ __ ] well shout out to the rams man
hello it's rams gang now yeah who's
happy
bro okay okay come correct but don't
come at all all right well listen
are you putting a wager on the game at
all
because i i feel like you and post
malone had a bet
yes a couple years ago yes yes yes yes i
did and i'm with i'm i'm i'm taking all
bets like whoever wants to smoke i'm
with it
so you are open to just open-ended on
all bets yeah like just a head-up bed
like
me i'm not doing none of the
little weird [ __ ] like oh
y'all gotta win by a field goal or y'all
gotta you feel me like um i'm not doing
none of that head back to the
[ __ ] how he went be a [ __ ] safety by
one point like
you know what i'm saying you already
have your super bowl tickets locked down
yeah my [ __ ] locked down
how much can you i mean i don't know if
you get them for free at this point
cause you are yg i'm assuming you don't
pay for these tickets but
these tickets are [ __ ] expensive i
don't like talking about about
financials
someone i know who's got season tickets
their tickets for the super bowl going
for 39 000 a piece yeah that [ __ ] is
crazy the suite that i'll be in
going for 700 000
jesus just for the one game
that's crazy and i'm in there and you're
in there i'm in there that's what's up
um yo this new record scared money
incredible record
um i loved i mean
i think that you know you played a lot
of the album for me a little while ago
and it sounded incredible but um
the video was crazy i just saw the video
looks like you guys i mean that [ __ ]
what was that like a four or five day
shoot so many different scenes so many
different the giant crate challenge like
you know that [ __ ] was like a [ __ ]
it was a three-day shoot but then
um we were shooting here the song was
supposed to been come out but uh during
a video shoot
a lot of the staff and people call code
that i had called kobe so we had to push
the
song back the video shoot
all that type of [ __ ] have to spend all
this extra money to get the [ __ ] cause
of kobe but um we finally
uh got it done and um you feel me the
record is out now
yeah i feel like it's like one of them
ones you know i feel like
it feels like a big bank it feels like
you know it's gonna it's gonna it's
gonna do do that kind of number like
when you first cut the record did you
feel that way yes i did
uh i cut the record and i told my people
i'm like bro
this is my first single and my piece was
like bro it's too early i said no my
[ __ ] i know when i got a record like
you fear very
was j cole eat like an easy call to make
um
like what you mean like like you just
hit you hit him directly there's a label
like you know is it a label thing or is
it i hate him
i had his number because i had bumped
into him
um
during covey you said he was doing a
commercial for his shoes
and i was in production for my shoe so
he came and he saw my whole program with
my shoes and [ __ ] then we was just
talking about fatherhood and all this
i connected with you but um you know i
uh knew jake cole for a minute and [ __ ]
he brought me on this tour like 2015. so
he feel me he been supporting you know
what i'm saying my whole [ __ ] so uh you
send me the call wasn't like
like i don't like reaching out to people
that i don't got no history with it like
nope just like yeah to try to do some
music with bro that should be weird like
you know what i'm saying um so yeah the
j cole she was like more on like organic
side like you know
no for sure um
with this album uh is there any
you and i have talked about
some of your albums that you
just kind of put out just to get through
your contract
yeah
those weren't albums those projects
right just about what i put out
i'm claiming two two of my
albums as real albums and that's my
crazy life it's still crazy which or a
lot of people would say obviously your
two best albums but it could be but when
cuz i treated them as albums when i was
exactly and i feel like um you were
saying that you're you're having the
same approach with this new body of work
that's coming correct yeah i'm having
the same approach with everything i do
here on out because i'm in that space i
own all my [ __ ]
like you feel me i'm moving like it's
it's all on me it's my time i ain't got
no bad blood with like i ain't mad i
ain't
i don't feel no type of way it's just
like all right it's time to get busy you
know what i'm saying like you got
through the initial contract yeah i did
my bed
i did my as a new artist right that's
like kind of what usually happens like
yeah but i should have been i could have
been out my contract way before like
it's just like but you know what i'm
saying like
um
i guess like everybody around me we were
still learning and [ __ ] and then my
lawyers was saying some [ __ ] and had me
thinking this was the only way all this
type of [ __ ] so
you know
but the game got the best of me
for that time well what i like too is
your transparency because i feel like if
more artists are transparent about maybe
some of the shitty situations that
they're in
it it will help like you know i feel
like i feel like it was the lebron [ __ ]
you were on the hbo [ __ ] well [ __ ] um
it was a no that was a draymond green
but you guys were talking about like you
know how
thus far you haven't gotten any royalty
money from your from your catalog
because your old deal
and i think that's very important for
new artists to see because like
you know it's a predatory business for a
new artist who comes in the game and
signs yeah you come in a game you
you from the streets you ain't got no
business people around you who yeah i'm
saying help you punch him right there
you get that big advance and you're like
yo this has changed my life this amount
of money i ain't even get a big
advantage that's crazy ain't changed my
life
because that was what that was like
originally like 2009
because that was the before two of them
booted no tutoring booty was out all
right that was the first single right uh
tutoring booty was out on some my space
[ __ ] and then when i got signed they
brought it over to def jam no
they wasn't even
like [ __ ] with the song the song just
was it kept moving in the streets and
the clubs and then
they was forced
you should be power 106 start playing
that's what you know what i'm saying
that's what was the game changer i
remember the first the first time we uh
not the first time i met you you did
like a high school show
in vegas but the first time we really
kicked it you were on that um
that tour with uh
with bobby brackens and ty
and you guys performed at lax in vegas
yeah bro that was a dm i remember this
and at the time i think bobby brackens
and you like like you you and bobby
brackens were like co-headlining which
is like a crazy and ty was like an
unknown artist
super unknown that's throwback bro
that's like throwback that was the first
time i ever met ty and you were like nah
this is the dude who did everything he's
on the hook this is you know yeah
i don't think all-star was out yet like
that's how long ago that was crazy
that [ __ ] is crazy right crazy for sure
and now you know it's it's like 26
million records later you just put put
the plaque up with 26 million sold yeah
that's light though that ain't even like
that's amazing though man they're
supposed to be like 100 million you know
what i'm saying but that's still that's
still nothing to 26 million is
that's that's a career yeah not for sure
and i feel like you just kind of hitting
your
you know just getting started bro 100
man
talk to me about the label because
you've had so many uh
different
variations of the roster right obviously
i think of kamiyah and rj and that era
of the label and then i remember right
before the pandemic uh you had pulled up
and uh with day salon who had by the way
she could sing she got some like lauren
hill type [ __ ] that's like crazy
um where's the label at now like as far
as just like who signed is that like a
priority for you to start to still still
put artists out yeah that's the priority
for me i still got day salon and uh d3
sun you know what i'm saying e3's dope
yeah so uh you feel me
like we have to plan
like right when kova hit like we had a
whole bunch of [ __ ] planned out but then
cover here
so you know like our side of the map
doing kobe was really shut down super
shut down yeah so i told the artist i'm
like look man y'all just gonna have to
like like we all in the same situation
right now we gonna thug it out
once all this [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying get back close to normal we're
gonna start getting you know i'm saying
we're gonna start moving and doing our
[ __ ]
so uh
like everybody did that so um dave
sullivan and d3 you know what i'm saying
they got [ __ ] coming soon
shout out to them d3 is hard
what is it do you have any sort of
current relationship with kamiyah
because i know obviously we've all seen
the interviews you know she's talking
about you know the situation and all
that like because i have you guys are
together for so long i feel like you
know eventually
emotions have to calm down and there has
to be you know is there is there a
relationship currently or
yeah we straight i just seen her and
[ __ ] i've seen her a couple of times
like
in the past a month
i'm saying we straight that's good
that is good man um who can you talk
about the album because i know a lot of
it's pretty much done right but the
album called pray for me pray for me
pray for me
that's all i can talk about
and the first single to scare money
that's the first record you know what
i'm saying and um it's coming soon
why that title
um
that title that's what the music um like
when i
came with that title
um
for me i was like halfway
like there with the album and i had like
a handful of records and i was just
sitting on the records and i'm like
i'm like i'm like bro like
if i wasn't trying to force nothing and
trying to come create some [ __ ] to
create some [ __ ] and try to make try to
turn it into like
like bring it to life i'm like no i need
to go listen to these mute like to the
music and let the music
like create the title you feel me so i'm
listening to the music
and then i'm like bro
it sounds like like like like like pray
for me like
i need help like you know i'm saying my
life is crazy life is crazy everybody
life past two years you know i'm saying
everybody been going through crazy [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying so
and bro this was like in like
july august august september when i came
with this title
and [ __ ]
and um
yeah it just seemed like both [ __ ] just
it's just crazy and [ __ ] so uh
yeah that's the title of the album bro i
was talking with dom a couple of months
ago and we were talking about how you
guys were supposed to have that super
group me and you have talked about it
before with him
and nip yeah right which would have been
amazing um
is there is there any of those records
that exist anywhere that you guys cut
that never have seen the light of day
like i don't think me dominip got in the
studio to start working on that like we
was having a conversation
and we was
finna go get a deal for that before we
even start working on it but then me and
nip
i mean it was supposed to do
like we linked up to do
a group project probably like two three
times
in the last time no
the last time
the time before the last time was
when we did [ __ ] donald trump
me and was working on a group project
called two of america's most wanted
and that's what the [ __ ] donald trump
record came from so we got records from
that
from that time so though so you you and
nipsey have some unreleased stuff that's
it sitting on a hard drive somewhere
yeah we got unrealy stuff
but it ain't it ain't like to a point to
where i could like put it out or like it
ain't
like
we was just getting started on working
on a project and like we did like
like two three songs and [ __ ] donald
trump and
you see me that was the best song
from that batch of songs and we ended up
putting it out
so at that time we like when we put our
[ __ ] down trump we like [ __ ] we need the
project for we already like we made this
yeah we made the best record the
yeah we made the best like we made the
best record and made the biggest
statement man that was that spoke to
that project like i remember because it
was around that time you were on tour
with g right and y'all did the remix and
and uh
that was like super thick in election
season yeah that [ __ ] was crazy that
[ __ ] was a wild time man you shot off uh
the g eazy because he you know i'm
saying he took a stance
you know what i'm saying with us on that
yeah and you had mclemore you just had
like the woke white dudes on the remix
um would you do a part two to that if he
runs again in 2024
no my bro nip ain't he you feel me so i
gotta let that you know i'm saying i
gotta let that be that or maybe just the
version called [ __ ] both of y'all
[ __ ] both of you cause joe biden's kind
of not doing a great job oh [ __ ]
yo stopping the interview got to tell
you about our good folks at odd socks
man listen go to oddssoxofficial.com
use the promo code 20 off save 20 off
some of the craziest socks you know they
got the ninja turtle joints
uh shout out to kool-aid you know what
i'm saying shout out to spongebob plus
they got the odd socks basics
these are my boys right here i love
these right here you get the plain black
the plain white very comfortable most
comfortable socks in the world to be
honest you know what i'm saying plus
underwear y'all cheese it draws
come on what are we doing go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and save 20
off the most comfortable underwear in
the world [ __ ] all that other [ __ ]
you'll be wearing on your ass throw all
the methicas in the trash all that psd
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] is all
listen man put the mod socks on your ass
cheeks and thank me later
um
talk about
your weed [ __ ] i told spencer i'd shout
him out on this interview because he's
one of my best friends and he's a
steaming pile of dog [ __ ] shout out to
my my boy spencer but he called me he's
like you better give me some [ __ ]
credit in that interview man
talk about 400 flowers fall in the
flowers uh
i mean this you feel me i wouldn't
like back in the day like 2011 like you
feel me i had did like
a strand with this gum weak um company
that was a long-time county yeah i did
ygo g back like like back then you know
what i'm saying but you from that's
before the wee [ __ ] was all the way
legal and right but i was so young i
didn't really know what i was doing but
i've been trying to figure it out ever
since then like a real situation so um
i finally like figured out the situation
and um
yeah we started putting out product and
[ __ ] ygog you got the the chicken and
waffles
uh
[ __ ] waffles
we got the blade
you know what i'm saying we got some new
[ __ ] in a drop all that and the thing is
crazy is like i feel like i don't ever
like remember you as a big smoker as
much as you just drink a lot yeah not
cause
so i turned into a like i was a smoker
when i was like high school like young
smoking smoking smoking smoking smoking
and then when i got to i'm like 22 23
like
the smoking wasn't
it wasn't my vibe because it was like
like it'll throw me off you feel me i
started taking my life like more serious
and just like aware of my surroundings
and like brother we that had me like
paranoid
be clutching
i think brother homie's trying to
like bring something fast it just had me
tripping like and then i had me like
thinking like i'd be like bro i'm a bum
like but what are you doing with your
life you didn't have all that you sure
wasn't mushrooms
that we brought on the gang bro that
weed bro that [ __ ] had [ __ ] in his head
tweaking
so like i just was like you know what i
don't think this [ __ ] for me and i start
sipping and then this drink it'll be
like
but the drink is like i don't be in my
head like that but then the drink got
his
cons too
you know what i'm saying
but um yeah i'm straight tequila
straight tequila now i smoke with the
homies and [ __ ] like i smoke like but
i'm not like the weed smoker out the
crew what is your go-to tequila
oh don leo blanco
that's so good i always tell people don
julio blanco i'll take that over 1942.
yup it tastes better i'm the one that
had everybody drinking 1942 and now they
drinking down julia blanco 1942 is kind
of overrated
yeah but it's like it's good it's like a
cute bottle i don't know that [ __ ] no
more yeah that [ __ ] is old i don't know
and you know what else i'm i feel like
as overrated as the [ __ ] class of zul
[ __ ] people just like to you know hit
like no that bottle look good it's a
good looking bottle bottle restaurant
the drink inside of it give me the not a
drink on that cool it's better than 42.
wait you feel like that [ __ ] like it's
more sweet or something right i like
casamigos or or don julia yeah i drink
females drink donald your blanco
casamigos blanco i drink down julio i'm
surprised with the amount of alcohol
i've seen you consume in our long tenure
as friends that you don't have your own
alcohol yet
i'm working on that
it's got to be coming soon man snoop's
got [ __ ] wine out here i'm working on
that
my [ __ ] is crazy though is it gonna be
tequila
yeah of course okay of course i don't
know maybe we get a yg hard seltzer nah
nah nah you feel me that's a [ __ ] drink
damn
that's [ __ ] beer is that [ __ ] beer
yeah that's [ __ ] bruh i love me liquor
i love me some [ __ ] beer that's cool
that's cool that's cool you know why you
drink that [ __ ] and it doesn't um it
don't have no [ __ ] calories in it
bro i'm from the streets we drink hard
liquor i respect that i used to be i
used to be a corona drinker see that's
cool if you drink like seven coronas
while you're djing by the end of your
done you feel like a bloated fat [ __ ] if
i have seven white claws i feel like oh
i just had seven bottles of water i'm
just gonna piss it out and i'm still
[ __ ] up
it's more of a diet decision because you
know
i'm getting older now that sounds like
[ __ ] for sure yeah
i sound like [ __ ] [ __ ] beer it is you
know what i'm saying
so we're going to sit here at that that
is that is now trademarked if you drink
uh seltzers it's [ __ ] beer that's
that's what i think from
from how i live and from
the [ __ ] that we that i think is cool
and what's not
you got your own lifestyle and your own
world
and y'all like drinking
white cloths
like hard liquor and brown paper bags
coming up uh next year will be the
10-year anniversary of my crazy life
no bro right 2013 or was it 2014. so
[ __ ] that's eight okay okay i don't know
why i'm trying to remember that like
error in my life
or do you are have you already started
to think ahead though like because
that's a [ __ ] one of the greatest
albums of all time uh anything special
for the 10 years in a couple of years
yeah no we definitely gonna do something
for sure we got to that's mandatory you
feeling that album changed my life for
sure
how is is uh mustard involved
production-wise on this album at all
no
is it get annoying like everyone always
asking that about like your projects hey
is mustard on here nah i guess like it's
regular
any other uh producers you could talk
about working with on the album
um
mean
oh like my producer swish you know what
i'm saying he got some joints on the
album
um
another young producer i [ __ ] with his
name little rich he got some joints on
the album
everybody else oh hip boy got up i was
gonna ask i i feel like you ain't hit
boy no hitboy got a thing on
he got a thang thing on the album you
got a thing on that [ __ ]
and then everybody else is just like
young
younging up and coming you see my young
and larry jay got a um joint on there
you know i feel like you but the album
is not done i'm still working so it's
like it's hard to just it's hard to you
know i'm saying
i feel like you have a great
ear for beats and you always keep people
around you that got a great year for
beats because like no matter what people
say about your [ __ ] your beats are
always on [ __ ] point like
and somehow like
that's an underrated uh trait to have in
music
is having a good ear for beats some
[ __ ] like nas forever had the
worst ear for beats and then he linked
up with hit boy and you know two
classics in a row shout out to hitboy
what's up y'all got to interrupt the
bootleg cab podcast we have a brand new
sponsor
and i love this sponsor i've been giving
them my money for a long time it's about
time they gave some back my bookie yes
that's right
if you are a gambler if you're not a
gambler let me tell you my bookie is the
best place to go all right super bowl
season is here super bowl 56 is right
here and trust me my boogie's double
deposit bonus is something you don't
want to miss if you sign up at my
booking now use the promo code bootleg
that's b-o-o-t-l-e-g
to have your first deposit matched
instantly
up to a thousand dollars so if you put a
thousand in they'll match your thousand
dollars and you get in on all the action
for super bowl 56 i mean seriously
joe burrow versus matthew stafford the
rams are playing the super bowl at home
in la what does that even mean because
none of these home games i've been to
them
it's a lot of out
outdoor fans coming in the 49ers took
that place over twice in the last month
we'll see how the bengals fans show up
all right this is the most important
game of the year it's the biggest game
of the year and you can get paid by
watching it my bookies giving you
everything you need to do it with that
double your money you can double your
winnings and the best starting point for
the big game is these super bowl prop
bets they're fun
anybody can do these right
hey mom what color do you think the
gatorade is going to be to get spilled
at the end of the game hey what about
that toy the coin flip is it heads or is
it tails whatever it is is matthew
stafford going to throw a stupid-ass
interception probably
probably
is joe mixon going to score a touchdown
i like it i don't know get in on that
prop back action and uh listen even if
you don't pick on who's going to win you
you could be a winner all right it's a
great look the prop bets are the most
fun for the super bowl so don't miss out
head to my bookie double your first
deposit up to a thousand dollars by
using the promo code bootleg
place your bets get ready for the
unmatched excitement for that super bowl
that is a thousand dollars in free money
that they will match so you deposit a
thousand they match a thousand bet
anything anytime anywhere with my bookie
let's get back to the podcast um you and
mazzy putting out the joint album
it's a big [ __ ] deal for the west
coast last year um
you have obviously been locked in with
maji for a very long time really before
he was kind of on this run that he's
been on where he was kind of like a
household name um
but what was like uh was it was it a a
purposeful thing you guys went in and
did it or were you guys just working
because i know you were in with dave and
like like you guys were working just a
lot did it just feel like you know what
we got all these records cut let's just
do a [ __ ] album like what how did
that nah really we didn't even really
have like we had started working just on
some [ __ ] before we just started working
and we did some records
and then um
like like it was like top of 20 21 i
think you know what i'm saying
they got pulled up on me like bro like
yeah i'm saying
like what you thinking about doing a
project and bro it's the middle of cover
ain't nobody really got nothing going on
we just like trying to kill tom
and then i'm like
hmm
mazzy that's my that's my fella fella
fella
you know what i'm saying i'm like bro
and then you feminist right before us
like
sauced uh me and mozzie be locked in
and started working right before i was
finished start working on my album
so i'm like bro this is the perfect time
to get in with brokers bro be rapping
like he'd be saying that he'll be
talking that [ __ ]
so like and i'm like a part like
you femme if you put me on a court with
a [ __ ] nba player bro i'm a hoop like
i'm playing like playing the nba
you feel me
that's what i think
but um
so i locked in with maui so
i'm like yeah this is gonna be good it's
gonna be some good you know what i'm
saying
like get my [ __ ] right for my [ __ ] and
do some dope [ __ ] for the culture that's
been needed anyway
you know what i'm saying with somebody i
i really [ __ ] with
so uh what they will have to um come
just like you send me the homie you
shouldn't be here rob he was our year
bro we need to do that we need to do
that right there yeah yeah yeah i'm like
yeah
yeah let's go
so you [ __ ] me we did it we uh we called
guys to be like yeah guys come on we
gonna do this through empire don't even
worry about nothing
you feel me guys he was like let's go
and we had fun we was recording having
fun you guys were like in cabo right
doing a lot of [ __ ] yeah we ended up
going to cabo to shoot the video in for
my birthday but we went to go shoot like
two like two videos out there and that
[ __ ] was evolved everybody came out
there blast and mozzie we had young
young man out there it was a gang of
homies it was like
it was like it was like [ __ ] galore out
there [ __ ] galore
uh
lady galore women lore pretty [ __ ]
galore yeah fatty galore stripper galore
a lot of imports from options a lot of
options now these are these women who
live out there are you i mean because no
no no no no no no i'm about to say a lot
of ig thoughts all around
no no women like women well you said
thoughty galore because you had to like
we we flew some thotties out there on
purpose because we got some thotty-ass
homies that need
thoughts and thought homies they
you know i'm saying they belong around
each other
so um yeah we had to we had everything
it was every type of variety of a human
you know what i'm saying good times yeah
it was like you had yeah it was fun
who's that everybody enjoyed their self
and it was like no disrespectful [ __ ]
was going on it was no it was none of
that it was real player fun the chef at
three yachts jesus it was cool you know
what i'm saying uh whose idea was the
belly
concept for the cover
um whose idea was i don't know it was
actually came out
mozzie me somebody actually came out
cold
is that um because you know mozzie's
been on your albums in the past right
yeah is that somebody who
i feel like
maybe like moving forward i'm like
people are going to want to want to
record with him on your album like you
know i [ __ ] might be bro like
like like bro i [ __ ] with my
gang land you feel me who's your
favorite uh up and coming outside of
your roster in la
who's your favorite artist that you're
just a fan of right now blast and
caitlyn from roof road
oh
and got
[Music]
you feel me the blue bloods clean too i
[ __ ] with them young [ __ ] too they're
killing it
and a baby stone gorillas baby stone
gorillas killing it
yeah yeah blue bucks i feel like kind of
got the club right now yeah i feel like
they're kind of like you know like there
was like an era where you would go and
only in l.a or certain parts in in cali
but you know rj kind of ran the club for
like a couple of years on some like la
[ __ ] you know i feel like blue bucks
kind of got that right now yo you they
gotta keep going keep their foot on your
neck you know what i'm saying is there
anything else uh entrepreneurial wise
you got going on you got the alcohol
come in the shoes people can i mean the
shoes sell the [ __ ] out right away
um but is there anything else you know
anything new coming for the for the
clothing brand or
yeah i got you know what i'm saying
snooze should always come and you feel
me just gotta stay tuned i don't really
like talking about [ __ ] i just like
doing it and being about it but the
album is coming you you know that you
send me the shingle is out now the first
one you know what i'm saying
um
i got my artist coming soon
you know we got big [ __ ] happening big
[ __ ] coming soon you got to stay tuned
um i just got into an argument about
who's on the west coast or the la
hip-hop mount rushmore
right for thinking errors uh-huh who
is on your mount what's more of la
hip-hop
i said i'm like
i'm gonna let y'all answer that because
i think if we're thinking of eras
you gotta you you've had like the last
10 years right but then there's like
kendrick there's
you know i feel like it's it's it's it's
it's a debate you know like
but so you you you said let the fans
answer
yeah that's the fans
it was dre snow
probably
i mean what you just said errors
errors that's what i'm saying like i'm
thinking you got to have one person from
each era up there type [ __ ] oh you
saying
oh i thought she was talking about
for this era no no no no just me all the
time oh all the time yeah you gotta let
you know what i'm saying like you gotta
let all times dre snoop poc
easy
dog
i think game should be on there too oh
yeah
but how many people was on a mountain
rushmore four but i think we can make a
five we
i mean if we making it whatever we want
to make it then it's probably like
you said you got to put ice cube up
there you got to put
um kendrick
yeah but see i was going off of before
so yeah
so easy
yeah i mean you got to put a cube on
there yeah i'll put q on here for for
our generation i'ma let you feel me the
people
talk about that you know i mean for the
last like 15 years it's you it's
kendrick
it's game
and then the fourth guy who am i
forgetting
it's really you kendrick and game and
nip that's the four
that's yo four
i mean somebody else's phone might be
different who knows who gives a [ __ ]
this is fair this is just fantastic
well the album's coming soon uh
hopefully sooner than later the video is
out shout out money back yo uh and uh
yeah man i'm looking forward to
appreciate you pulling up hey can we do
a um
a next year
rams cardinals bet now yeah what you
want to do how much you got like which
one about a thousand
no no no i'm not in it for that
i will take a photo in a rams jersey no
i'm not taking a photo in a niners
jersey no in a cardinals jersey no get
your kylie i'll take a i'll take a photo
in a hopkins jersey okay so you take a
photo in a cardinals de'andre hopkins
jersey but i can't do that i'm just
telling you
but that's your friend do that yeah but
you trying to make it about a bet and
like you trying to have me go viral and
look crazy no this should be a good bet
because i'm just whoever's got the
better record next year
you should feel good about that
bro
look at the squad look at the coach man
shot me what the [ __ ] is he this dude
talking about stop playing
so so so it's a bad you're gonna make
let's spend some money
eh
i'm not batting money you're richer than
me bro you'll be booked out like better
yeah like some money
scared money don't make no money we
could do
hundred
500
bro a thousand
see i'm not gonna i'll do four hundred
i'll do four four hundred i'll do
[ __ ]
400 next year regular season record
who's got the better record overall why
you want to let's do game for game
that's that's going to take too long to
get four hundred dollars
game for game seven games so first time
we play you we we beat y'all
no no no we're playing twice i said the
first time we beat y'all fine
or do you want it who gonna win the most
out of them two games
but then it's like what if it's if y'all
want it's a todd and it's a tie [ __ ]
okay let's do that all right
all right babe we can do that we do that
i don't know what you think let me think
it yeah because we probably see y'all in
the playoffs but see i don't know about
the playoffs we're talking regular
season only two divisional games
see that's not that's not a
like
like you betting on it to be a tie but
like that's gonna be like it it's going
to be like
you feel me that's not a good bet it's
cool but like we can break even like for
sure easily fine the first game
let's just bet just game for game bro
okay fine each game
of the game so i might be down 800.
yeah you might be down honey it should
be a terrible look
it is what it is
but who's keeping count
yeah well listen uh he's also open for
all bets for the super bowl don't know
any rappers from cincinnati and oh no
disrespect to cincinnati i'm sure
there's some people bubbling out there
but you know people from ohio
ohio yeah but like i know people from
cleveland they're not banging cincinnati
they say cincinnati is like a redneck
ass city
oh
i got homies from cleveland they're like
we don't [ __ ] with cincinnati that's
like some redneck [ __ ] i'm like
i don't know but joe burrow's sick so
you know yeah joe bird was sick chase
sick there might be some lsu uh people
you know they got some they got some
people up on they squad for show
but guess what
welcome to la
this is a home game baby it's a home
game super bowl half time is going to be
crazy yg you'll be there stop mentioning
that 49er [ __ ] is over with like hey how
annoyed were you that i posted that on
instagram i wasn't even tripping this
whole text to be like your petty is [ __ ]
yeah i'm just like well you petty like
bro you trying to smoke my name made me
look bad that's crazy you know what's
funny is i came away from that game
saying man that sucked but at least i
got a nice piece of content
you ain't [ __ ]
there it is